PANEL, THANK YOU.
I WANT TO TURN NOW TO THE FOCUS
ON THE NEXT MAN WHO COULD BECOME
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, THAT'S CALIFORNIA
ADAM SCHIFF.
SEAN DUFFY REFERENCED HIM.
IF HE BECOMES CHAIRMAN, HE'S
VOWED TO CONTINUE TO SEARCH FOR
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION THAT SO
FAR NOBODY HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVE.
I'M JOINED BY FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY, ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ANDY McCARTHY.
IF SCHIFF TAKES CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE INTEL, WHAT MIGHT WE
EXPECT SPECIFICALLY?
>> I ANY WE EXPECT EXACTLY WHAT
WE HEARD -- I THINK WE EXPECT
EXACTLY WHAT WE HEARD FROM YOUR
LAST PANELIST, UNTIL MICHELLE
CALLED HER OUT ON IT, WHAT YOU
ARE GOING TO GET IS, YOU KNOW,
LET'S LOOK AT THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING, LOOK AT THE FINANCING
BEHIND TRUMP'S BUSINESS EMPIRE,
LET'S IN PARTICULAR LOOK AT THE
FINANCING OF HIS REAL ESTATE
ASPECT OF HIS BUSINESS.
OF COURSE THEY'LL SAY THEY NEED
THE TAX RETURNS FOR THAT.
AND WE WILL BE OFF TO THE RACES.
THAT'S WHAT IT WILL BE FOR
HOWEVER LONG IT LASTS.
ALTHOUGH IT WILL BE OF GREAT
BENEFIT POLITICALLY TO THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE COUNTRY
WILL LIKE IT.
>> Laura: THEY'LL ALWAYS
OVERREACH, TRY TO TANGLE
EVERYTHING UP, AND TANGENTIAL
ISSUES THAT WILL NOT HELP A
SINGLE AMERICAN, HAVE A BE JO,
HOLD A BE JO, AND RAISE WAGES.
NONE OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
IT'S PAV LOEFIAN WHERE THE
DEMOCRATS SAY, LIKE THEY'RE AT
THE GATES AND THEY JUST WANT TO
RUSH THE GATES AND GET THE STUFF
DONE.
ANDY, I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT A
REPORT THAT CAME OUT JUST A FEW
HOURS AGO, JOHN SOLOMON'S PIECE
IN "THE HILL" ABOUT FBI
OFFICIALS AND DOJ OFFICIALS WHO
HAD BEEN GETTING FREEBIE TRIPS
TO VARIOUS FOREIGN DESTINATIONS.
AND ONE OF THE CHIEF
BENEFICIARIES OF THESE FOREIGN
TRIPS, FREEBIE TRIPS, WAS ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
OF COURSE ONE OF THE MOST SENIOR
PEOPLE IN THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT'S GOING THERE?
>> YEAH, THIS HAS BECOME A
REALLY BIG PROBLEM, LAURA.
I WROTE ABOUT IT A FEW MONTHS
BACK WHEN IT CAME UP IN THE
FINANCIAL FRAUD INVESTIGATION IN
NEW YORK.
THIS WHOLE IDEA OF THE FBI AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAVING
THIS KIND OF INSAYS TO YOUOUS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE MEDIA,
TRADING INFORMATION, AND THEY'RE
GETTING FAVORS OUT OF THIS,
THEY'RE GETTING TICKETS TO
SPORTS EVENTS, THEY'RE GETTING
ALL KINDS OF BENEFITS OUT OF IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
OUGHT TO BE ITEM ONE THEY'RE